hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are back at round
four and it's Magnus Carlsen versus
Maxime for Sheila Grove really an
exciting game featuring probably a
never-before-seen opening and before we
check it out if you still haven't to
join the tournament
both of the term is that we're gonna
cover today not cover but I will be
streaming them hopefully if if you know
the term end doesn't last for too long
but the links are in the description
below first thing you're gonna see so
the links to the both tournaments are
there so do join we're gonna have a lot
of fun now that being said let's check
out the game Magnus opens with efore and
of course we have c5 by Maxine going for
his Sicilian hopefully a knight or
Knight f3 d6 d4 captures captures in now
Knight to f6 and here usually pretty
much Knight to c3 a6 is an instant but
here Magnus plays Bishop to c4 and it's
such a weird move as it hangs the e4
pawn it's it's quite interesting Maxime
looked at it for quite a few seconds and
in the end he just played east sexy
declined at the pawn and it's very
interesting if you capture the pawn what
happens you get Queen to h5 of course
threatening to capture on f7 the bishop
also supports that East six blocking the
bishop and now Bishop to b5 check in
here it's just complete madness if you
walk with the knight then just Knight
captures here really just beautiful
stuff and of course if you if you block
with the bishop doesn't really matter
still knife characters attacks the Queen
and it's just a whole mess of a position
and you know it could be that Carson
just prepared this to avoid the night
off but there's also this fantasy
chesley going on and there are like
these questions that will we see a night
off on the board so maybe Magnus just
played it also plays the fantasy chess
League and then he just played Bishop to
c4 to avoid the knight or if not to lose
any point is there so who knows anything
is possible but okay Maxine ignores the
pawn with e6
we have castles here and the Bishop to
e7 and now there are a few games in the
database that actually reach this
position and but the move Magnus place
is a new one here he just goes back
Bishop
the three now guards the pawn and it is
as a move seven that we have a
completely new game so nice to see six
challenges the night and the Magnus
captures at night captures with pawn
captures and now c4 gaining full control
of the d5 squared the so-called Marazzi
bind we have castles by black and now
Knight to c3
now with E 5 and now comes Bishop to e3
we rush up to e6 both players just
continue development and the Queen to e
2 now with more support to the c4 pawn
the rooks are now connected
we have 9th to d7 probably with the idea
of trading over the disappear but also
maybe even f5 in the future is an idea
with rook F to be one this will put
pressure on the d6 pawn if the bishop
ever moves from east 7 and now Queen to
c7 maxime also develops the Queen
connects the rooks and b4 now now Magnus
is ready to start pushing on the Queen
side and the maxime immediately
challenges it we have a 5 a 3 B captures
a captures and the now rook captures on
a1 trading off a pair of rooks we have
rook to b8 going after the b4 pawn and
now rook the b1 and the max team goes at
night to have sex which will support the
push of the pawn to d5
Magnus goes h3 and here you have to
decide whether you push the 5 or not
it's it's just the thing in the Sicilian
defense if you can put d5 and you're
okay then you're okay if you're not okay
then you're not so here maxime just
pushes it and here we have a nice
capture fest in the center captures
captures we have it captures Knight
captures and everything just gets
captured off and now Magnus as he does
had with the bishop pair slicing over to
the Queen side he starts pushing his
passport so the material is completely
equal both players with the bishop pair
but Magnus does have the past beep on
which he now of course hopes to push
forward with E for now attacking
Carlson's bishop here but now Magnus
doesn't react to this by moving the
bishop but rather by attacking Maxim's
Bishop here and the problem with the
problem with moving the bishop for
example this update is that now b6 is
indeed very strong after Queen to c6
you're gonna get better of the a6 and
well your own
is now just blocking your attack here
and this point is just extremely strong
it would be very hard to hold this
so instead Maxine went for each capture
Sundy three Carson capture than B five
and now rook the d8 attacking the Queen
and of course putting the rug behind the
past pawn Maxime now also wants to push
the past pawn queen e4 again with the
still keeping an eye on the pawn and on
the bishop here and now well you can't
push d2 right away Magnus will just
attack it with rook to d1 so not not
really gaining anything there so instead
we have Bishop the f8 first not allowing
the Bishop to remain a target here but
now Magnus goes b6 attacks the Queen we
have Queen to c2 attacking the rook now
and look the c1 now attacking Maxim's
Queen and here both of them were
extremely low on time and work simply
the Queen to b3 here quinta b2 is a bit
more precise because Queen to b3 allows
a certain move so even feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this move as it does win the game for
Magnus while I give you a couple of
seconds so those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
move the world champion missed and for
those who just wanna enjoy the show it's
b7 and now well what what do you do here
rook to b8 you now go after the pawn the
pond does seem to be lost in the next
move but the idea is rook the c8 and
this is how Hawaii prevails
now you're just the threatening to pick
up the rook so Queen captures on b7 but
now you capture the Queen and after rook
captures and now just Bishop here and
you're threatening checkmate so black
doesn't have time to start pushing the
pawn you have to make some room for your
king but now just rook captures with
check King here and rook to d8 keeps an
eye on the past pawn and it's just game
over for Maxine however Magnus missed
this idea he thought that if he pushes
the pawn to b7 that black will just be
able to grab it and instead he went
Queen to f3 and here now it's Maxine who
pushes the pawn d2 we have rook to d1
the rook nicely defended by the Queen
and now h6 getting rid of some
background weaknesses and here Magnus
was like three minutes on the clock
Maxine was
around two minutes on the clock so
finally b7 but now rook to b8 and now
it's a bit different as you don't really
you don't really have any threats
so Magnus just captured the D to pawn
and the mock scene captured the b7 pawn
and now it's a bit different now it's
exact same material with both players
with three points on the Kings side so
Magnus started putting his pawns on
light squares as he does have a light
square bishop we have rook to b8 and our
King to g2 are slowly improving the
position rook to e8 and now rook to d7
going after f7 the black King still a
queen still defends it though we have
Queen to east 6nr Magnus just offers a
queen trade we have characters
characters and the g6 now
maxime also preparing to put some points
on light squares h4 and now Bishop to g7
and here h5 we have g5 and definitely
making some progress here as those pawns
are now on dark squares which makes them
targets however there is suggest no way
to reach them king of three we have
Bishop to f6 and now King Teti two we
have King the g7 King to d3 now and rook
to e8 by Maxine with f4 by Carlsen and
now G captures we have Bishop characters
in the rook to a3 check King e4 so
slowly but surely making progress
rook the a6 and now King to f5 maxime
just 2 goes back with the bishop and now
rook the b5 attacking the bishop and
here we have worked the f6 check by
Maxine King King to e4 and now rook the
e6 check once again and here Magnus just
repeats if you do something else than
just Bishop blows back but here Magnus
repeats and Maxime also repeats and here
we have a nice draw by repetition of
moves so it was in this position that
the players agreed to a draw so really
wild game incredible opening in game 1
this Bishop to c4 move by cross and
really really impressive stuff you know
we might be seeing a lot of these in
bulletin and blitz games online just
giving up this efore pawn but yeah now
it was this one moment where he where he
had the chance where he could have gone
for it if b7 was played but he missed it
and then the game ended in a draw so
that's round one for you I do hope you
enjoyed that
could have gone either way but it was
mostly Magnus in control for the entire
game but yeah great great defensive
ideas by Maxime and in the end he was
able to draw the game yeah once again I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Frank true slow asset rivers Paul
our hints and Antonio Vecchio and Robert
avoid avoid klenda for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video sure thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and the join
the tournaments in the description below
see you soon